wait so how old are you when you just
like became a legend like when you
passed 1,700 that was maybe when I was
about not eight or nine and then really
the watershed was was world youth under
12 when I won the world youth under 12 I
realized that I gotta keep doing this
whether I like it or not the only thing
I'm capable of doing well and quite
possibly remains really pressing my life
[Music]
hey what's up Daniel so great to talk to
you after so many years yeah for sure do
you I'm so sorry for the the way else oh
no problem at all absolutely not I was
experiencing my own technical
difficulties
hey let's go great minds think alike
exactly exactly yeah wow it's such a
small world I honestly I can't believe
you wait when Wenham like like I don't
know Mike a month ago or whatever when I
was like oh yeah I know datum they're
just key in chat were you like who the
[ __ ] is it like what is he talking about
or were you like cuz I know you say you
did like exactly remember but was it
like when I were you skeptical at first
no I mean I looked up the tournament
standings and I was like oh [ __ ] like
Jonah as for honey like in this
tournament and that's when I kind of I
had a sort of a brief recollection I
don't remember a lot about that
tournament he only did yeah remember is
playing this guy at suya I that's
literally the only thing I remember oh
[ __ ] the guy that beat me yes I remember
playing him and I remember a couple
moves from that game just like he
blundered something and I remember that
my last round opponent in that
tournament offered me or asked asked for
a take back and I remember like
delivering this speech to him about how
I would love to give him a take back but
it's a rated game but that's basically
all I remember and it's just wait did
you tell him that while you were playing
yeah yeah I remember like whispering to
the guy you know like I'm sorry but you
know that's a lot of maturity for like
like OS 7 or 8 year old how old are you
I was I was probably seven almost eight
yeah I remember that
well your brother your brother was
playing too right my brother at that
point was playing but he wasn't playing
that very tournament I were my brother's
four years old me we were both 1700 at
the same time and that's approximately
when I sort of shut up and he got you
know he was already in high school so it
was much harder for him to keep going
but he had 2100 eventually so that's
pretty good my mom always wanted me to
be like a great chess player right but I
was like so bad about like actually
trying to improve and like study and so
I would just like play in tournaments
like take like like summer camps
sometimes and then like
I just never I'd never really put like
the the time or the energy out for a
nice trying to play that games and [ __ ]
and then I just dude literally like she
she always brought you a or she's like
you could be like Daniel man like look
he's like Chess Champion and you're just
there like playing Pokemon like you you
could you could you could get there to
one day during that like you gotta just
you guys just work on it like remember
like that kid you guys were sitting next
to each other like and now look at him
and now look at you and then I'm just
like I don't know I don't I don't know
what I'm doing I don't know how to get
better like I just want to play games
and [ __ ] but now it's just it's just so
like crazy I mean all these years back
blushing but my mom is one of your
biggest fans I'll say that I appreciate
that means a lot to me well she saw me
now maybe she would retract that
statement all respect that's amazing
thanks gopher for the sub yeah that's
absolutely and I'm so happy you're back
in chess and you've lost none of your of
your strengths I think I was very very
impressed honestly and I'm our day to
impress so I'm glad to be a to do a very
small part to help you get even better
and and progress through Bob champs so
basically I would really appreciate it
it's the start of the winner's bracket
tomorrow right where you're playing yeah
so well yeah I play move first round
mm-hmm mm-hm and there's two games now
to game any match yeah two games and
then I think if we draw it's like a
three-minute game or something mm-hmm
it's a sort of a playoff I gotcha so I
was thinking I mean we talked a little
bit beforehand of course and we can put
an emphasis on openings but I guess if
there's anything else that's sort of in
the whole realm of the game that you
struggle with or that you fear that you
don't like
even if we're doing let's say openings I
can still try to put an emphasis on
explaining things in a certain way to
help you in other areas of the game so
I'm gonna try to like combine stuff but
is there anything that comes to mind in
terms of stuff that you feel less
comfortable with and I know you told me
but maybe you can expand a little bit
more
so I have a better sense of sort of what
to emphasize yeah I guess like I'll play
out some openings
I think if Iife I'm in an okay position
I feel like a lot of times at least when
I'm playing people at my level like I
can navigate it decently well but I
think I struggle sometimes like
conceptualizing what my like what my
what my plan for the game should be and
like how to get there especially when it
comes to like cuz like pawn moves are
critical for that right and I think I
struggle sometimes like like having the
confidence to be like okay so I need to
like I need to break open the position
here and I need to like set this pawn
break up here and I need to like just
you know make sure it's reinforced and
then go for and then sometimes like I'll
do it it's like correct and I'll look at
I'll analyze you can have four it's like
oh yeah good job but then on sometimes I
get it wrong and I'm just like oh [ __ ]
like I that was like that was dumb or
like I was I was focusing on like the
wrong area or I was trying to like do
like like multiple things or something
like that I don't know I think I think I
I'm okay like just like playing out the
game but I would like to be more
methodical than that kinda and like
really understand what I'm doing in like
every game that I play better and then
like I think that will help me like
shore up a lot of like my weaknesses cuz
like I think I think I'm pretty good
with like finding the right like tactics
I think I think I'm decent
I like endgame from what I've seen
compared to like the people I play
against but I think sometimes I'll just
get into like a bind in the middle of
game and I don't know I might be wrong
about like I might be wrong but this is
just like my no no no I believe you sort
of know yourself you know yourself the
best so everything that I that you tell
me is very valuable so sort of you feel
a little bit more comfortable in like
sort of short-term tactics but it's more
of the long-term planning understanding
what to do perhaps an undefined
positions pawn structures spawn break
stuff like that mm-hmm
yeah okay I didn't try to advertise that
yeah and and you're at that stage where
we can talk about a lot of things at
once it's not you know if I'm teaching
someone who is like eight hundred nine
hundred I have to isolate things one by
one okay right now yeah talk
specifically about the role of you know
how to see a fork in this position but
with you I can sort of give you the
bigger picture and and explain stuff
more holistically so to speak so I'm
definitely gonna try to do that okay it
sounds good I'll let you know if I if
I'm confused or I'll try to ask
questions and stuff too
definitely and I in terms of openings is
there something you prefer to start with
I mean I can walk you through something
that you wanted to learn what sort of is
your top priority in that regard white
or black and then sort of I'm completely
your disposal in terms of teaching you
some opening or reinforcing an opening
you already know we can basically talk
about anything and I'm sure our
conversation will will naturally flow
into various areas yeah we could we
could try a you try walking through like
an opening or two and just help me help
me understand stuff better mm-hmm
so if you think that's good I think
that's great so I guess the question is
from the white side or from the black
side you wanted to learn so against 1.e4
you said do you play the Sicilian what
is your own opening so that's a so yeah
I think I think I think I I typically go
for the Sicilian and how do you feel
when this is sewing do you feel more
comfortable than against d4 or less
comfortable then it gets 1.d4 um I I I'm
not I don't mind too much either but I
do I do like the Sicilian I like playing
like alleys I I think I like playing the
accelerated dragon just feels pretty
good most game most games but I also
know I mess up when I'm even when I'm
playing it in like optimally figuring
out the plan and like making the best
moves and stuff - mm-hmm
do you want to start with a quick
rundown let me give you three options we
can throw the quick rundown in the
exciter - dragon sort of shore up
although maybe holes that you have yeah
sort of walk you through the London
system I know you kind of wanted to look
at that from the white side or I can
introduce you to an opening against one
d4 such as the Kings Indian okay so I
think those all sound pretty good um we
can start do whatever you want like I'm
down for any of them okay well let's
start with the Sicilian with black
because until you reach 2,000
onee 4 is going to be by a country mile
the most common movie phase so it makes
sense to invest your biggest asset with
the black basis is going to be knowledge
especially because you play the Sicilian
which is uncommon at your level most
people play e5 mm-hmm
makes sense to know it really really
well and the accelerated is a great
opening I've taught it to some students
I don't know it necessarily at a GM
level but I think I know it enough to to
guide you through some of the hoops so
let me invite you to an analysis board
ok just invite hey I see it awesome
hey I like your pig thank you that was
from 2007 actually I never bothered you
that just tells you how lazy of a person
I've never seen Dave same breadth a way
too much work so basically you can face
the black side and I will face the black
side as well do you see my loops yeah I
do okay so so the one thing that
glitches often is when you make moves
sometimes I don't see them but I just
try something you told me to click on
the 1 2 3 I like that that subtle flex
bro
ha ha ha what did i do what did i do
weights are you the highest rated blitz
player right now on the site I am but
I'm not over a like a car is higher
rated than me I think globally on chest
comm I may be number 4 or 5 right now so
crazy but I have fluctuate all the time
alright
what a beast thanks I mean I there's
blitz players a lot stronger than me so
yeah I'm being I'm being I'm getting
coached by were literally the best
players in the world and after this
lesson I'm still gonna be no I'm just ki
matter I got an improves I actually like
I'm not gonna get my hopes up but I
think I'm actually an improve so much
but let's I'm a terrible don't get your
hopes up I'll actually be worse I will
see if I succeed ok so your games
I would imagine ok let me do this I'm
gonna do this professionally so you play
the accelerated dragon exclusively
against before
correct is that bad no that's great but
is that's a question do you play I think
so or do you experiment with stuff uh I
think I try to play it most often yeah
okay so here's what I'm gonna do if you
give me a second I'm gonna go into your
game history and I'm gonna and I'm going
to download your last 300 or 400 games
Oh God and I will check but it's what I
will do that for is to see how come how
people respond against the accelerated
most commonly and so we're gonna put an
emphasis on that if that makes yes okay
yes because that's sort of practical
preparation because a lot of people in
this position they play Bishop c4 they
don't play d4 that's the open Sicilian
yeah I don't know if that's your
experience as well
Bishop's oh yeah I've seen that I've
seen that sometimes too yeah but I think
I think I'm more used to be four cakes
and then continue well how are you
downloading a bunch of games so I'll
just talk um there's a feature or you
can you can download batches of games
and then I'm basically transferring them
basically transferring them to a program
called chess space I don't know if you
know what that what that is oh yeah I
heard I heard that and then what I'm
doing is basically alright guys feel
going wild in my chat but basically what
I'm doing then is I'm downloading all of
your games into one database and I am
there is a feature that allows you to
check what your opponents play and I'm
doing that right now so then we can see
what what I'm typically faced with
rather than like what you're like oh
yeah it's like what GM would play
exactly because we can prepare the
mainlines and a lot of people do that
they just blindly prepare the mainlines
but that doesn't help if you never face
them so I'm guys in my stream I am
sharing chess base so I'm showing you
how I'm doing this so prepare against
black now let's see so out of all of
your black games
efore 69 games and d4 36 games okay so
he for c5
one second now let's see Knight f3 35
games so by far most people play Knight
f3 and then d4 15 games Bishop c4 11
games so Bishop c4 is close behind Thank
You human for the bit so I think we
should actually start by looking at a
system against Bishop c4 because a lot
of people play like this okay sounds
good let's do that and that will move on
to g4
okay where the heck is my okay there we
go
so this ship c4 now why do people play
this move so commonly because I am I am
I am okay
well it's like it's just a natural
continuation of like development it's
it's like you know the tout the Italian
game so it's like very common to play
against anything and then also I guess
people in my level look for like
pressure on the f7 squared - bingo
so yeah that's exactly right people play
the Italian against the Sicilian that
that's not exactly how life works you
can't just play the telling against
anything and the reason yeah it's not as
good and the move that I'm gonna teach
you is and this is not an accelerated
dragon type of move but I just think
it's the best move in the position
that's the movie six yep mm-hmm which
basically shows shows white that putting
on mr. bishop on c4 is not as effective
as it is in the Italian because now the
bishop is just staring at this point so
the placement of this Bishop in the
Sicilian is very much suboptimal so does
this move kind of makes sense e6 yep
makes sense for sure I think what uh
I've often found myself going like maybe
g7 to start my my dragon chopper dance
and then and then trying to like and
then sometimes people like people just
go like Knight g5 or something and then
and then I'll play like East six and I'm
like okay good job times you can do you
can do that in air Knight g5 v6 is just
good for black he's gonna lose a million
temp because now you attack me too so if
you prefer to keep the spirit of the
accelerated
is a good move as well okay so let me
see what people let's see what people do
against you so g6 I see you've played
five times two people castled and one
person played d3 one person played
Knight g5 and one person played d4 okay
so let's keep the spirit of the
accelerated then let's look at g6 now
after he castles Bishop g7 C three the
only reason I was going to recommend the
movie six and you can decide is because
in this position there's a very annoying
sideline that one guy played against you
where white goes c3 yeah and the point
is just to control the center with a
move T for now mm-hmm as I'll show you
each six avoids any of this stuff
because you immediately aim to control
the center with d5 it's a very much
Saladin eventually having slots at that
1/7 yeah I like that better yeah and
it's you don't have to know a lot you
don't have to learn a lot I'm gonna show
you some cool ideas here now most people
are gonna Castle here and the move that
I really like in this position is the
move Knight to f6 okay
now bringing the knight out attacking
upon what comes to mind if you were
playing white what would be your first
temptation here to develop your Knight
to c3 to protect upon okay so Knight c3
is absolutely one of the moves we'll
look at another room is e5 that some
people will play okay and here I'm gonna
show you well there's that a cool move
here but I'm gonna show you something
simple that gets black a good position
finally some people might play rook to
e1 they depending upon this way and
let's start with the move Ricky one
because this highlights a tactic that I
want you to be aware of in these
positions okay
lack can actually take on e4 with this
Knight oh and then d5 bingo and you
might like it
well what have I gained from this trade
well you've eliminated White's Bishop
you have the two bishop advantage you
have very nice development for your
pieces you can just talk your Queen away
on d7 and could you tell me where this
Bishop on ca might be long in the future
how will you develop it probably
being peon keto it thing about seven
that's exactly what you're gonna do in
it look at how harmonious your pieces
are gonna be let's say we fee in keto it
immediately which is possible we go
Bishop e7 x-ray the rook this Bishop
goes to 7 then we counsel do you see how
harmonious how much of a bind black Oz
and whites position here yeah it's
pretty juicy out I like it
so this Knight takes e4 is something
that I just generally want you to be
aware of and that's why it's a better
idea for white to go Knight c3 you can
still take on e4 here but it's not as
effective because Y can keep his Bishop
now here we play the move t5 according
to plan
yep controlling the center it's acting
the bishop are you afraid of a check on
you one absolutely not how are you gonna
parry this check in the nature of c6 so
Bishop e6 is not bad but then you still
have to develop this Bishop on that face
so I would kill two birds with one stone
by playing so yeah yeah so thank you can
then castle in the next move don't have
to worry about anything on the e-file
and here black has a terrific position
this Bishop on c8 given an opportunity
can jump out to g4 mm-hmm you've got
control of the center if white plays T
for himself how will you meet this move
um let's see so I wouldn't
oh I would just go c4 attack the bishop
bishop moves then could you don't
overthink it just continue our
development as normal whites and then
Bishop geez for exactly why it's been
you know [ __ ] around inside nice you
develop your Bishop to the square great
thing about developing your Bishop to g4
okay is that first of all you have this
pin people hate pins even at my job I
hate them me too they're annoying so
another problem is if White says well
I'm smarter than than this this voyboy
gene I mean he calls himself a genius
but I'm a bigger so here's what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna take here I'm gonna
double this pawns that I'm gonna chase
this Bishop away from g4 first of all
you have two ways of dealing with this
you can move your Bishop back in fact
the knight yep this is a very common
tactic which causes tremendous practical
problems for white because you just
can't get rid of his pin yeah I would do
it I would do this randomly and now it's
called the void gambit and I would
sometimes went off of it and sometimes I
would just like I would I would like I
would fly because I'm trying to like
attack the King and I just couldn't find
check me well that's a common problem
that's bad that's a little bit of lore
for you that's interesting so you're
aware of this and you'll actually like
this sack I loved it I mean I love sacks
in general yeah me too it's so it feels
so badass I think we have similar styles
I mean not unsurprisingly because we
both played in the same first tournament
true we're molded in the fires alright
so are you you don't have I don't mean
to ask any personal questions but are
you from the Bay Area originally yeah I
was born in Berkeley and Wow actually me
and Hans like I was talking to him the
other day and we had hella
it's hella funny cuz he went to like the
Berkeley chess school too and I used to
go I used to go there too as well so
well I was born in San Mateo oh [ __ ]
yeah we're Leicester City that's awesome
dude so crazy that is crazy what a small
world yeah I just moved to Charlotte at
5 months ago I was in the Bay Area my
whole life oh [ __ ] what brought you out
what brought you out to many things like
I graduated in June
first of all obviously I wanted to live
alone and if I lived alone in San
Francisco I'd have 18 roommates hands as
really gonna matter like a 200 square
foot apartment right and Charlotte
there's something called the Charlotte
chess center which is founded and
directed by one of my best friends and I
actually well precoded I I moved here to
to work for the chef center and teach
classes here and also I obviously teach
teach privately too so it's a
combination of things I have a lot of
friends here chess friends here so
awesome dude and it's a little bit more
affordable in Charlotte to be honest oh
yeah for sure is the tide but anyway
wait that's enough about me I'm my life
is boring I was gonna say already I feel
like smart you're you're actually such a
good teacher
so I already I already feel I haven't
done anything you're you're a good
student so so this sacrifice is that
doesn't mean you have to sacrifice every
single time but especially when you have
this kind of eternal as they call it in
Russia in an eternal pin roll [ __ ] yeah
makes sense which you can then reinforce
by bringing your queen out to f6 so very
common idea here how would you go about
doing that I mean the Queen can't
exactly jump over the bishop maybe you
go
Bishop before set up a new external pin
and then you and then you bring the
Queen to f6 so that's that's what I
would call them up wha the most popular
wrong answer so I am just to warn you
I'm of the Russian school of chess which
means that gross the hell out of you
occasionally no I'm all I'm all for it
but the way to think about this is every
single piece on the board has to be
fulfilling a role wait wait I just I
just had a like a paradigm shift I asked
tuned as you said it was a wrong answer
I was even second-guessing it I think
I'm messing up because the whole point
of the SAG is to keep pressure on the
king right so if they I am started if I
start diverting resources to like the
Queen side like rook b8 like Bishop e6
for inch I'm kind of losing I'm losing
the plot right so I should keep
targeting the King so like something off
the top my head like Bishop d6 makes
more sense it keeps more pressure there
and it gives you a room for the
to come in bingo that's exactly what I
was gonna tell you took the words out of
their mouth
I don't know how dare you do that I'll
let you know that I realized what I did
wrong right so your play has to be in
concert one move has to be in concert
with the previous one Bishop before yes
it's a pin but also it's not as
effective of a pin because a pawn
defends the pins piece when a Mon
defends the pin piece by definition the
pin is less effective why because well
in this case the Queen can't exactly
move away from the pin but if there was
a pawn on Gigi oh the Queen could
potentially move away from the pin
that's why you sacrifice untrue for and
then why the spin is so effective so
Bishop teasing yep that's like wrestling
like someone has to tag in for the Queen
before that and I could even move
basically such as the king what's a tags
in with King G - but your reinforcements
arrived just in time what moves you make
now oh and then I go don't let the Queen
escape from d1 yeah did I go Queen f6
and go and again White's an even bigger
trouble here literally completely tied
down and some people my god it's brill
let's say that white just bites this
time I go I don't know rook you won just
some random move and basically asking
you well how do you improve your
position this is where a lot of people
struggle because they start looking for
a knockout blow and yep not you not in
every position do you have like an
immediate yeah blow sometimes you need
to just accumulate the pressure very
slowly and gradually this is one of
those cases could you name a way to do
that yeah you could either try to bring
a rook in to eat from yay or it seems a
little hard to get it in there but har
wait what'd you say heart isn't slow
because you have like morals yeah yeah
true cuz you have you have him locked
down that's true thing goes so could you
name a plan here how do you bring this
rope you go rookie a go rookie it and
then the only square you really have
free is rookie six okay good and
and then you could go an f5 bingo to
give space and then reg h6 yeah yeah I
managed Rick g6 that's Oregon
you were test for okay yeah exactly
excuse me you have any media win here
actually do you see it oh oh yeah Bishop
takes f3 Queen takes Rick and then Rick
g6 exactly this is a classic
transformation of the advantage the pin
has served its its purpose you end the
pin and you win the Queen good let's go
that's exactly right so this plan takes
what 1 2 3
3/4 moves I I teach some of my sort of
high rated students what I calls a 3
move rule which is that if an idea takes
3 moves or longer it's usually
unrealistic but this is an exception
because white is completely tied down
and a lot of people don't understand
that chefs can be a slow game not every
idea is instant and not every winning
position requires you to find some sort
of crushing blow a lot of people waste a
lot of time trying to find that and then
they find something that looks good but
just relinquishes the pressure true I
have I have found myself in that pickle
definitely often tonight yeah it's like
ever it's like every position you're in
in your games like it's like a tactics
puzzle where it's just like oh [ __ ]
check me bingo that's exactly that's
what I try to convey to people like when
you solve it on a tactics you get a
disproportionate view of chess master
save tactic boom boom boom boom yeah
tactics are like the freaking you know I
was gonna make a weird analogy but I
decided to spare your audience from it
you know Ferrero Rocher candies oh yeah
I love those yeah they're so good
so it's like tactic so like the nut at
the center of the furoshiki and you like
you have to eat all the chocolate first
gladly bro yeah now I mean all the
borough's share exactly now I want to
get basically the eggs are pretty
expensive though huh they are yeah but
they're like premium they're like
premium yeah they're definitely say
although I mean I don't haven't
yeah last year I bought them they were
on sale it was like four dollars off for
a big-ass thing I'm him and I was I
scooped it up you can I was like a year
ago though so III need to look out for
again yeah I can't thank you I can't
have one of those in my apartment I was
received a so basically to return to
this line z5 and thanks ppb with a sub
20 months
what else could like to hear why can go
Bishop b5 and and now actually what you
should remember is that this move
creates somewhat of a threat of going
Knight to e5 mm-hmm
so is that something to be afraid of not
really you can go Bishop e7 and if I go
is 95 again it looks scary because white
attacks c6 but you can simply reinforce
the knight on c6 while attackers you
have 95 o so Bishop d7 is o Queen D 6 or
even Queen c7 oh yeah either Queen b6
I'm always afraid to put the Queen in
White's grill like this because mm-hmm
you know the Queen as I say sometimes is
sort of the Supporting Actress mmm and
the Queen wants to be in the shadows so
that it doesn't sort of stick you know
it doesn't get in the way of it's a long
range piece so you don't need to put it
close to something real yeah makes sense
it's like if she's an assassin right and
that's a general guideline that doesn't
mean again everything I say to be taken
with a grain of salt sure sure sure sure
okay so so this is nothing to fear um
and and the last thing in d3 you you
still go d5 same thing takes takes
Bishop goes back there should be seven
you castle develop you've got a nice
Center this is a pretty intuitive
position is does that kind of make sense
from sort of a general perspective this
type of position how to play it what
shape so what should I be ideally
looking into you after I Castle and
stuff yeah so it depends on whether he
white allows Bishop g4 if he does you're
looking to play mr. G so what should be
playing hei like ASAP right in my
opinion yeah so
three castles I don't know let's say
Knight c3 and now a good solid way of
developing is to prepare the development
of the Bishop to e6 now if you develop
d6 immediately I have an annoying move
Knight g5 so how would you prepare it
oh wait give me one second sure take
your time
ah all right okay let's go
sorry about that no problem okay
so essentially you want to develop your
Bishop here
but the problem is White has this
annoying pesky moon ig5 so how would you
pave the way for the development of this
Bishop maybe h6 bingo h6 is always a
safe move here and then you develop your
Bishop to e6 and I'm gonna give you a
couple of guidelines here too I'm gonna
give you two different plans in this
position one is to play on the Queen
side and you already have two pawns so
what you would ideally like to do is
place a third pot on b5 which would
serve two purposes the first is you
might trap the bishop with c4 yep the
second is what's not I'm sleeping on the
job
exactly and you also just pressuring the
Queen side maybe you'll push the pawn to
d4 and then you're a pawn it depends on
what why does how would you go about
preparing this move b5 this is actually
a bit of a tricky question because if
white develops let's say his Bishop to
f4 you can't go rook b8 so what would
you do to prepare that move maybe a six
yeah a six is great and you might say
well what does this accomplish what just
goes a four to stop that move but a four
is actually a very serious positional
concession because it deprives the
bishop of this potential square so a
move like c4 I'm not saying to play it
immediately but it will bury the bishop
on a2 which is again a very serious
positional concession and in addition
it's creating this weakness on the
before square onto which you can later
plan tonight potentially yep so how
would I go about playing this position I
would just improve the position of my
rooks and slowly for me remove c4 so I
would go rook e8 rook c8 and then I
would prepare the move c4 whenever
you're ready you play this movie to bury
this Bishop and then this Queen could
come out to b6 attacking this pawn
pressuring f2 etc etc so this is what I
would call the piece play positional
strategy in this idea in this very in
this position you got you the alternate
plan here is very aggressive it's maybe
a little bit more unsound but it's also
potentially rewarding and that is to
prepare a sacrifice on the h3 point
let's go now you're talking
so there's a caveat here you know
there's an asterisk yeah for limited
would have promote shipping charges
apply it's not as simple as it appears
so basically what you would do here is
you would play the move Queen d7 I would
start regardless of trying to play b5
and I would induce this yep just source
its hand yeah just so I can't pin you
potentially with the bishop hmm and if
he doesn't play a four a four then we go
through with the b5 yeah so for example
I mean what would you do here with what
like what comes to mind possibly Queen
d2 and think about and think about
sacking or taking on each six maybe so
let's say you were scared from the black
side of him taking on h6 how could you
prevent this from happening even if it's
not necessarily objectively that good
which it's not maybe queen h7 I mean
King a diamond oh that's exactly what I
was looking for this is a business GM
level move King age seven hey you know
like yet oh no oh exactly I'm happy you
said it as quickly Z because it's not
intuitive to move your king like this
but the king is actually a great
defender yeah he's an extra piece
exactly people and myself got to think
about it like that
yeah the King got a respect the King and
say no I'm not saying bring it out to
freaking f5 yes like try to throw checks
with the kick right right exactly like
the king is cool it's not that cool but
it can fulfill these menial defensive
roles Thank You Charlotte chess Center
for the five gifted subs King welcome
let's go Charlotte's jester thanks for
employing my boy Daniel yeah that's my
good good friends Peter G annatto so I'm
going to give him a shout-out I'll talk
more about Otto so let's go yeah he's uh
I give him a lot of crap but so that's
the last nice thing we say about him
okay so so basically okay let's say
white coats rook 81 and you go b5 so do
you see what the threat is if Y plays an
empty move what do you do
oh four black yeah so let's say I go
king h1 here what do you do here just
see for bingo DC and then and then yeah
then you take DC again very important
not to take BC because then the B extra
square easy stuff queenís Bishop is
tractable why can trade down the D fall
but it's just empty noise because
eventually the bishops gonna get yeah
then you lose the psh yeah by a lot of
people do that when I when I have when I
have it when I found a good play they
just sort they like throw random check
or something something like that but
then I'm just seeing their smirking like
oh no I got you you son of a [ __ ] you
exactly you can't you can't stall you
ahead of this one
tsuya would fall prey to this for sure
this is what I should have taught you
all those years ago poor plan dude I was
undefeated until I play I went three
games in a row somehow and I wasn't even
good and then I lost that kid and I just
ting she's my he's my kryptonite
unbelievable we gotta we gotta find him
that's good so if white creates a square
forest for its bishop now with all of
this done we switch gears and play Queen
d7 potentially preparing another 10 subs
from Theatre Jesus thank you hey let's
go Charlotte chess center on a rampage I
just want to hear and say my name
against the Charlotte chess center
Charlotte chess center that's right
one-of-a-kinds anyways so thanks again
so you're preparing this awesome would
say the best chess center I absolutely
unmatched and I'm not even biased its
unmatched I mean they got you there so I
mean IIIi believe it exactly well it was
the best before I came I brought it up
brought the Lafayette uture you're
supposed to Rose stop stop being nice to
me no I got I go i agreement to your own
roast that's good enough so basically
I'm gonna make a couple empty moves for
the sake of explanation
you would bring your rook to e8 and at
some point you Whaley sorry to keep this
dragging I would erase you but I would
roast you but I think my mom would get
mad at me hahahahaha she's like why did
you say there were Daniel show him some
respect your dad the joke
I forgive you then that explains it okay
you're off the gate you're off the
probation
thank God so basically the rush excuse
me the rationale behind this sacrifice
is pretty self-explanatory you're
exposing the king Queens attacking the
knight the reason I'm not in love with
an idea like this is because again the
Queen is not necessarily as effective as
it appears as it might appear when it
attacks alone it needs yeah forces and
especially the best partner for a queen
is the night the night Queen tandem one
of the strongest and chests oh [ __ ] okay
so for example let's say I block this
attack with a move Bishop to g3 could
you do byes strategy and this is a
little bit 5head but first of all do you
see this Bishop on b3 yep get it the
hell out of the picture before you do
anything get it out of the picture
what's c4 bingo c4 so tapes lock the
bishop out then decide what to do this
is called playing on two flanks and now
you actually have an amazing move that
basically wins the game and this move
creates a threat and it involves another
piece in the attack but it doesn't do so
directly that's why it's kind of hard to
find but I want to give you a chance
okay let me think so
I'm thinking my first instinct is rook
d8 and my second instinct would be
Knight g4
okay so Knight g4 is tempting because it
creates this but the promise of the
bishop still ruins it the reason I'm
thinking of rip DEA is because could I
could I could displace that that uh that
g7 that g-tube first our g3 Bishop
eventually to with this move as like a
setup maybe okay so let's say I move my
Queen to f4 for example did you have a
follow-up in mind and then you could go
Knight h5 good thinking the problem is
very concrete I'm gonna pick off your
other night here oh yeah but you're
thinking in the right direction I'm
gonna give you a no maybe so maybe maybe
it's maybe it's just it's just an IH
fire in the first place yeah so that's
probably the second best move and it
would be winning because you're
threatening to capture the knight on c3
with devastating consequences why
because the board is so open white is a
very very annoying resource here and
that's the move Queen to d7 now that's
not something I would necessarily so
conceptually your move is excellent
don't get me wrong here conceptually
your move is is exactly right it's just
a freak freak kind of defense and now
you either have to trade Queens which is
disastrous or give up the c6 Knight
which is position still remains
complicated because you could pick off
the bishop but in reality the best move
is Bishop c5 oh yeah and what a threat
law what does this create what threat
because then you can take the bishop on
gt-r because it's pinned big Moz fans
and the King can't move so black I can't
even really stop it yeah I defend the
bishop with Queen f4 and this is where
Knight h5 comes to the comes to the fore
because now again you're reinforcing
this threat yeah that's Pawar's and then
it checks not there anymore
bingo so the Queen on h3 guards this
square rook guards this square notice
how every single piece on the board
fulfills some sort of it sometimes
auxilary I mean or primary role yes
regards this fun this Knight just
sitting there ready to come to d4 that's
sort of the night
image of of middle game chess is every
piece on the board fulfills some sort of
duty or role and you can name it very
clearly yep
so if there goes a way to c7 then you
can either take with the Queen on g3 and
trade Queens and get a favorable endgame
up two pawns or you can take with a
Knight and checkmate him which would be
perhaps preferable no but that's more
straight yeah I don't think I can stop
the million threats here let's say why
it goes night H - just some practice you
hanging off could you finish me off in
this position and you're welcome to make
moves however you want to do it you can
tell me the moves you can make moves
okay oh I can move the pieces yeah I
think you can I should be able to see it
but it sometimes glitches you can try it
okay let me think here so what if I go
boom
okay that's an excellent first move yup
driving my King out and now I hit you
with yeah you have a very good check but
and now barely intuitive and now I hit
you with
ah I almost have it take your time yeah
as long as you need I mean I never would
rush you mm-hmm
it's a little distraction tactic as a
bit of a hint but not much of cocoa I
think it's what it's called distraction
tactic
I almost got it no problem the I've
spent an over an hour thinking about
walking for so
thought about wait oh you see my arrows
oh my god I gave it away
sorry ok so I was trying to think about
what if I take the rook and then I check
and then I check on d4 and then when the
King moves then I have the discovered
attack on the Queen possibly or as good
as what I was gonna suggest that's what
that was right yes yep that's I sorted I
know it's it seems sketch browse trying
to like calculate it out before we like
you started drawing on it it doesn't
seem motional I'm sorry I did cuz I
forgot you also see my arrows oh no
that's okay but I know chats gonna be
like oh boy just like saw the answer no
no no stop stop capping but no I really
was trying to figure out I was like okay
so when the King moves and I'm pretty
sure I can get like I just got like it I
think cuz right now the problem is that
your Kings not a square where my knight
can check you but if I can just displace
you yeah then you can do it you have no
you're absolutely right and I'm sorry to
do the error so basically what you're
saying is if as soon as the King moves
on a checkable square you leave exactly
yeah and here's what I love about that
approach the reason a lot of people
struggle when they're attacking is
because they only look for checkmate and
they get fixie I want to check my
opponent that King is out in the open I
need to check me check my chocolate and
you don't find checkmate you start
panicking you lose on time but what
you're doing is that you're trying to
find ways to transform your advantage
you're using the open position of the
King to find a way to win the Queen
which wins the game just as effectively
as delivering checkmate and that's
something you should always keep in mind
is there a way to transform my attack
into a material advantage yep make sense
I just you know I just need a winning
position after all right I have to win
the game right there and then you could
also by the way check on g4 that's what
I what I met with distraction tactic
rook has to take and now you take the
rook on you one okay and if the Queen
takes the knight as a small tactical
warmup
Oh rookie three bingo another
distraction tactic wins let's go exactly
exactly so so multiple ways of winning
you found both of them good job so that
I'm confident in your attacking skills
once you get this type of position so
you can see what the idea is of sacking
on HP it's very speculative so if white
defends well he might in
urghhh up apiece for two bonds it's not
like you're giving up the full house you
have two pawns for the piece that's not
such a big price to pay you know what I
mean
so it's not that's the biggest risk
you're ever gonna take but it is a risk
because it is a sacrifice of a piece so
you want to do this only if you have all
the puzzle pieces in place sort of for
sure that makes a lot of sense but
that's sort of the lay of the land in
terms of this type of position
[Music]
you